this is a production of Cornell
University
well thanks very much today I'm talking
about reputation neighbors understanding
the market for wine and this work is joy
it's this presentation draws upon a lot
of joint research with Marco cust Negro
in my previous graduate students is now
a professor at Colorado State University
and nan yang who is also a former PhD
student who is now a economy Trish
enforce cover and then some other some
other colleagues I also wanted to say
thanks to thanks to Brad record for
setting this up and and also to mark
smith and Bob steams at Geneva so I'm
happy that that some people are there to
to hear this talk and so I will get
started I will today I'll be talking
about three drawing upon some results
from from three papers I will have some
I will have a few equations in this in
this in this pit in this presentation
but I promise not to bore you with
deriving the details just bit just
basically describe them inward so i'll
just briefly touch upon the equations
but what what I'm but i'll talk about
today is to model some producers
incentives to invest in quality when
firms have their have their own private
brand name but they also share a common
name and a reputation which is which is
commonly the case of wine will discuss
that somewhere and then secondly i have
two empirical parts to this paper 12 to
estimate how names and reputation nest
within each other to identify producers
with increasing specificity and how that
how that affects prices and then finally
i'll also look at examined the spatial
relationships of neighboring wineries
with market data and use and use GIS
with that so so why is just a
fascinating product i think i got
interested in it I enjoy drinking wine
but I also I also find it a fascinating
product that
that I love this quote from Robert
Mondavi for example one wine in the
valley and he's talking about Napa
Valley one wine in the valley is bad for
every one bad wine in the valley is bad
for every winery in the belly one good
wine in the valley is good for everyone
so so the point is that that wine is a
class of products in which each firm
wants to develop its own reputation for
quality and each firm wants its closest
neighboring wineries also to produce the
highest quality so think about that not
that's sort of different than a lot of
places where they want it where when
firm wants to have the hyatt be known
for the highest quality and to be able
to out-compete everyone in one you want
to be from an area where all your
neighbors also produce good produce high
quality wines geographical indications
from from Europe may be another example
and I'll talk I'll talk about possibly
other examples and so in this so we can
think about maybe a quality cartel where
where there's a cartel where they can
jointly choose quality would be the best
situation from from the industry side
for this so I'll get into I'll get into
reputation so wine wine is something
where your reputation really matter so
people people buy wine based on what
they think about it and so I like I like
this picture here with the woman in a
wine store actually this looks like
Costco instead of wine store but it
where there's just a vast number of
different wines to choose from and it's
and it can be daunting to select the one
that would be best and so so wine is an
experience good and there are three
classifications of goods and economics
based on information one is a search
good or your perfect information the
second is an experience good where you
you can't determine the quality until
after consuming it and then the third is
a credence good and the Creedence good
is something where even after you
consume it you don't know for sure what
the quality is and I've actually had
people argue that wine is really I
credence good because it's based based
on the marketing so they don't they
can't verify that the marketing tells
them it's
it's good okay so but when quality is
uncertain you ex ante you don't know
what quality is when quality is
uncertain then then both regional and
firm reputations can play a role in
consumers choosing line and so and so
because of that consumers are willing to
pay a higher price for products that
come from a high from high reputation
firms and from high reputation regions
okay so now let's think about let's
think about reputation it can that that
I from it the way that economists think
about it a the broad definition of
reputation is an association of a name
to an expectation of quality and so in
reputations are latent so they aren't
directly observable so we can't we can't
just it's not something where where we
can have data just on reputation we have
to infer it it's all so subjective it's
based on people's opinions reputation
can have increasing specificity also so
you can have reputation for different
things and I have this example of the
Russian Motor Co dolls where each one
can nest inside each other and so so we
see it here this is a BB from from
Rutherford within NASA Napa Valley and
so it's interesting that there are
reputations associated with all these
things of that I've circled bv
reputations associated with the baby
with the ABA Napa Valley and the sub ABA
retherford so it's just a very small
area with in Napa Valley there is a
reputation associated with the year you
here that's a good year for why there's
they even list the winemaker on this
bottle and then reputation reputation
associated with the with the with the
variety also so it's I found this one
interesting also that Napa Valley's of
course at California Wyatt Californians
not listed on this bottle so they're
they're drawing their reputation from
from Napa Valley and from Rutherford
rather than California so then let's
talk a little bit about about how market
characteristics affect reputation and
how reputation effects effects the
product so
what I'm going to talk about here is
mainly between firm reputation
collective reputation or a combination
of both and how that depends on the
characteristics so markets in which that
have collective reputation only so it
only depends on the region you're from
let's say is some examples of that are
not our non-traceable firms with a
recognizable region of origin and so
coming from Washington I would give the
example of Washington apples so there's
many producers and when you buy a watch
in Apple you don't know you don't know
who which farmer produced it you only
know it came from it came from
Washington so that's an example of non
tres beau with a recognizable region of
origin then you can have there are
markets with firm reputation only and so
that's a traceable traceable firm you
know who you know which firm produced it
but you don't know but the location over
up is irrelevant and so an example could
be firms delivering services or an
example I would like I liked using its
Starbucks ok so starbucks it doesn't
matter if you buy it in New York or
Washington or anywhere in between you
know you get the same you get the same
coffee and it has a reputation for the
quality of the coffee it makes then a
next we have we have sort of this this
but I've been calling a dual reputation
structure so reputation with both firm
and collective reputation aspects and so
with that you have traceable firms so
you know who you know who produced the
product and the location is also
relevant so an example here I listen
example this is another Washington
example but Lea Nettie's wines and walla
walla washington solian eddie's is sort
of a cult vine and it's really hard to
buy it you have to be on a waiting list
for three years even to buy it and then
Walla Walla has a reputation within
Washington state as a better wine region
you might also consider for example
Honda and Japanese cars although maybe
we need to go to a different example
from that now but um okay so so I
thought the so thinking about this I've
had some I've had some people I've had
some people say well does this apply to
anything else you know is this just as
does this only apply to Y and I thought
well this actually applies to
universities okay so i can say so the
analogy with wine with both with this
duel reputation structure you can have
instead of the steak for wine we have
the university so we have a cornell here
and the american viticultural
association instead of that we have the
academic unit so applied economics and
management sort of the grape varieties
we can say feel so the field of
development economics for example then
we have faculty members and then the
vintages are the PhD graduates I house
I've got resilience women Susan Appa and
Travis library and then we have this
quality measure shoot even so we have
rankings awards and placements of your
students so so I was thinking that's
another way that we can that this
another way that so this model doesn't
only apply to wine we can think about
other other examples also okay so let's
move on just I'll quickly go through
just talking about previous findings the
first the first people that really
talked about talked about this was
landed in Smith and they they found they
looked at Bordeaux wine and they found
that that consumers rely more on
reputation than on current product
quality so lag quality was more
important than current quality in
estimating that the market price of wine
there's been a number of studies that
have that find a premie nor quantifier
premium for for a region of production a
lot of them have been in wine there have
also been some studies on geographical
indications that I've done one for
example but they find that the
geographical indication is also
important and then i would put also
related to this are these state
agricultural products of arizona-grown
jersey fresh or Washington Apple saw
these all these state promotion products
our prop projects are also similar to
this that they're trying to promote the
state and give a collective reputation
for the state well so now the
theoretical literature there the study
of reputation really goes to the early
1980s Oh Carl superhero and then crepes
and Wilson and they did these studies up
firm reputation so so for example
Shapiro Shapiro it has a dynamic model
and and finds that that it's it's
necessary to have a price premium in
order to justify an investment in
quality because of the leg
if there weren't alike then we'd have
we'd have low quality and they're meant
a lot of studies on this then a to roll
out of clues in 1996 first coined the
phrase collective reputation and I just
thought this was sighs in grad school at
the time and I just thought this was
fascinating collective reputation and so
but to roll did something very
differently than the way I'm thinking
about it he's damn match model and he
had he talked about collective
reputation of a group of workers and he
and also describing the persistence of
corruption so two roles toros ID and
this is sort of a funny quickly story
that if you for example if you are a
member of a crime family like the Mafia
okay and you you want to go you want to
have an earn an honest living and go
straight because of your association
with your family everyone's going to
think that you're that you're not going
straight so you might as well it's so
that's nuts to roles but that's what
troll' talks about in this paper then my
one of my graduate students Jason
Winfrey and I had a paper in AJ in 2005
and we looked at collective reputation
as a common property resource so for
graduate students i live in economics i
would recommend it's it's always I think
it's nice I did Natural Resources a
movin mighty one of my PhD field so I
thought if well collective reputation is
just like a forest or a fishery you know
that people that it's a it's a common
property resource that people want to
extract from and so so that was sort of
our ID and i'll talk about this just a
little bit more in one other slide but
most of the literature either focuses on
on private or collective and in many
interests in many instances there's a
dual reputations of both exists and
especially in in wine and so and there's
also a new literature that's forming on
geographical indication and a recent
paper is men apiece and giancarlo musky
knee that was just published last year
okay so my first paper in the said i got
started in this is with as I said with
Jason Winfrey he's now professor at
University of Michigan and we looked at
a
we we were looking at the there were
many there was a lot of a lot of people
griping in the Apple industry that that
alpha prices are low and consumers were
saying oh the Apple quota eating quality
is bad and so we were and we found some
empirical evidence that reputation was
in declining trying to trying to
estimate it as a latent variable and so
we're thinking of well why is that why
is it falling over time and so you can
think about it as a dynamic problem
similar to a natural resource so so if
it's a common property resource than
firms have the incentive to extract too
much and so they extract by selling low
quality products at high prices and free
writing on the group reputation and so
it's just like a common property
resource their shadow price is not this
is too low and they extractor rapidly
and so this was sort of a new way of
thinking about collective reputation and
we could show that as the number of
firms increase then the collective
reputation decrease into the niqua
librium and so this actually the sort of
interesting thing in this is that it
provides an argument in favor of quality
standards and and I've talked to some
lawyers about this and that it's they're
typically argued as a Zen I trust that
you're trying to keep a small number of
firms in the market and so that's why
you'd have quality sensible but we're
saying know you're trying to protect
your your common brand ok so I'll move
on to the model I'll briefly i'll
briefly talk about briefly talk about
this model i know i don't have a lot of
time so i'll try to go through this
pretty quickly but we just we have we
have n risk neutral producers in a
production district no entry so you can
think about it that people in land so
that's the barrier to entry you have to
own land to to have a vineyard ok each
is maximizing his net present value over
an infinite time horizon and it's
subject to the evolution of both
regional and firm reputation so we have
to reputation group and firm and all
firms produce a fixed constant quantity
but they choose and they choose their
quality level so you can think of the
quantity is normalized to one okay and
based on the land size and and the firm
and collective reputation in each time
period are Markov processes so they
evolve over time which are
commercially controlled by the producers
and so reputations are a function of
past quality just like you'd expect
prices are a function of reputations and
then and also the presence of a
collective reputation implies that firms
in the productive region share
comparative advantage relatives too from
outside the region so you can think of
terroir okay so if you're in this region
that's really good for growing wine you
can grow better wine okay so as i said i
would have some equations but i'm just
going to point to what they are so here
we have you're maximizing or net your
net present value profits over time
price times would begin out of one and
price as a function of of firm
reputation and collective reputation
minus the cost and the cost of selection
of quality okay subject to a state
equation for reputation so how
reputation involves over time so
reputation depends on past reputation
and then and then this is a change so we
have current quality minus the past
reputation so if if quality is greater
than reputation then this will be
positive so reputational increase just
like you'd expect if qualities but low
reputation will decrease and then here i
can talk with us a little bit more but
this is this is the speed of consumer
learning so how fast they find out about
it how how big the time lag is and then
we also have this firm visibility
parameter so if you're more visible than
you then you
you'll have a bigger effect so first
I'll go to this one this is the this is
the state equation for collective
education so reputation just similar to
the other one depends on past reputation
and then and then we have we again have
this this difference between quality
between quality and reputation and all
this stuff is right here is that we
allow for different weights for the
firm's so we might say that if one firm
is bigger than the other firm then they
have a bigger effect okay and we else so
and then this last one this is a dynamic
game so this last one is just the
transition equations of the private
reputation of firms as well as the state
contingent choices of quality so that
each firm is maximizing depending on
everyone else's choices so it's just the
normal the normal game theory approach
ok so then then we we do allow so in the
paper and I and I left a sign-up sheet
for the paper i can email anyone i can
email you in the paper but each firm
observes private and collective
reputations and anticipates what each
firm will play in an a strategy subject
to the evolution of the complete system
we have speed of consumer learning
that's between their own wine we have a
firm visibility parameter and then we
have we allow for different ways and if
and they have to be greater than greater
than or equal to 0 and add up to 1 okay
so then i won't go spend a lot of time
in this but we have we have in
simultaneous bellman equations to solve
to solve the system and it's a complex
it's sort of a complex system to solve
we first solved it analytically but you
have to make all these all these severe
assumptions so we decided to simulate it
and and so i'll talk about the
simulation results and the simulations
are the semi we we do that by
parameterizing it with california why
data so instead of well instead of
assuming a lot of functional forms we
utilize california wine data a
to estimate to estimate the demand and
how reputation affects prices we use
observations from the Wine Spectator
magazine then it spans 10 years of
vintages and that includes blind tasting
scores and we only use we're only
looking at red wines and the wine
spectator ratings are used as proxies
for quality their blind quality
assessments by excerpt experts and their
where we think that their eggs adjust to
prices so they experts don't know what
they're tasting and they just rate them
and we can we can debate whether that's
a good proxy or not but that's what we
used each observation includes the
producing winery their rating the
american viticultural association area
the vintage and the price and it's in
2003 dollars and then we estimate a
hedonic a tonic model with quantile
regression in order to capture the
changing structure of reputation across
across price segments okay the class
side so as usual in economist it's
always hard to get cost data and so what
we're actually we're interested in the
cost of quality of providing quality so
in terms of these ratings so we just
calibrated cost function that's a linear
marginal cost to get quality and so this
is and what it's basically doing is so
that we can solve the problem we can
solve the system and so this allows a
numerical solution to the problem as
well as offering a first order
approximation to the underlying cost
functions we're not we're not defending
this to the death or anything but this
is this is how we this is all we solved
it so just a discussion of the
theoretical quickly of the theoretical
results with homogeneous firms and we do
in the paper we consider we consider
lots of different variations on this but
I'll just talk about in terms of in
terms of homogeneous firms that
investment in quality is increasing in
in own private reputation in other firms
collective reputation and in other firms
reputation and collective reputation and
so this implies that a decision by
another agent to invest in quality
induces similar
so in that in that dynamic game by other
agents and it's primarily through the
price effect in the collective
reputation and so so this is this is
what we expected that it's nice that the
calibrated that the simulations also
gave us that under this duel reputation
structures returns from private
reputations mitigate the free writing
behavior that we found that that Jason
Winfrey and I found in that collective
reputation problem so it mitigates some
of that associated with the common
property resource of reputation and then
so so then another interesting aspect is
that the equilibrium quality and
reputations increase from the low to
high conditional price quantiles and
we'll talk about that a little bit more
in more empirical results and so what
this means is that higher price segment
producers capitalize on greater returns
from investing in in quality okay I want
to just quickly compare cases so there
are I'll talk about three cases first
regional planner so this is if there was
a regional planner that could tell
everyone what quality that they that
they would produce a sort of a quality
cartel where everyone was told exactly
what quality produce so and this would
be so this is sort of the this is a
special case in it they will invest in
they'll invest in the sort of optimal
quality so you can almost think of it as
a quality monopolist or cartel they'll
invest in the optimal quality so the
marginal cost of investing for each firm
equals the discounted marginal benefits
to the industry and so they'll include
the total contribution to both private
and collective reputation then so this
this sort of intermediate case that's
that's probably actually the case in the
industry in this duel reputation
strategic game each firm considers the
marginal value of his own his own
reputation and collective reputation but
the positive externalities that are
accruing to other firms are not are not
internalized okay so there's a little
bit of a loss from from the externality
and then in this in this final case
collective reputation only model
the marginal benefits are smaller still
so you'll have the lowest quality inn in
this in this final case and because the
end of the inability to influence
private reputations makes further under
investment quality and so this is the
public good this is the special case the
public good problem that I looked at for
watching apples ok so then then to talk
there's a related paper that we talk
more that we do more empirical work on
this was published in aje with Marco
cuss me grow and and he we added one of
his colleagues at Colorado State Chris
Gilman's and in this one we we wanted to
we wanted to look at how we estimated a
hedonic model for wine as a function of
product attributes and reputation with
quantile regression and what were one of
the key things that were doing is that
were we consider passed quality
consistent consistency of quality and
many name logic longevity in the in this
in this so what we do is that we're
we're interested in how how names and
reputations nest within each other to to
identify to identify producers with
increasing specificity and and we find
and one of our findings just upfront is
that that the premium for good names
migrates from collective for the lower
cost to to specific for the higher for
the higher end and so so I'll show you
some of the results from this I think
this is these are some pretty some
pretty interesting result sweet these
are quantiles so this goes from it's
from the 20th to the 80th Cornell so the
lower cross lines are down here and
these are all wine spectator wines so
there's no jug wines or bad with you
know low quality wines it's all it's all
better wines but we
from the 20th the 20th to the to the
80th and as we see here we so we have
this is a DA passed quality so this is
the this is sort of the collective
reputation that you can think that and
so the collective reputation is goes up
but it's pretty flat and you can see
that for the lowest quality wine it's
the most important okay and then this is
the firm passed quality and the firm
fast quality is less important for the
low cross wine then the then the
collective reputation told firm
reputation was less important for the
lower hutt Swain and then we see it
about the semi 70th quantile it crosses
so we see that for the and it's going up
pretty pretty well so we see that that
as you get as you get two more and more
expensive wine then people care more
about the specific line then about then
about the region you didn't think about
that maybe in your own experience so if
you're just buying like a you know eight
or ten dollar bottle of wine you might
look at 0 0 x 1 from Australia or
something like that or I'll buy one from
by a New York one today you know and you
won't but as you if you wanted to buy
let's say a fifty dollar bottle of wine
you'd be more careful about who about
who the firm is that you're buying from
okay and interestingly the the current
rating for the wine is actually below
the reputation for love the whole for
for the whole spectrum and then I also
have I also have a consistency and this
is this is based on standard deviation
of quality and so and so we're
interested if how can help how
consistency or if we have a bigger if we
have a bigger variance in the in the
scores over time how that affects the
the price yes
Alexis oh okay yeah this is this a
decent premium these are review premium
for for an increase for an increase in
in each number each score each increment
of score okay yeah and so then this
well okay so this is consistency so this
is it's actually the standard deviation
so smaller is better okay so yeah this
yeah so explaining this up so if as the
standard deviation gets bigger than
there's more there's it's less
consistent okay and so yeah so maybe I
should have measured this a different
way but we but it's it's sort of the
mirror image ok so for for the okay so
for the the ABA if you have an
inconsistent ABA so it hurts more than
the current then the firm and then and
then it's interesting that it's almost
it's almost at the exact same level that
at that 70th percentile that it crosses
in that and the eighth in the the firm
consistency so firm is is not consistent
it hurts more it hurts more for the more
expensive than the lesser expensive the
other thing that we are interested in is
firm on Gemma T ok and so so if people
if people value that a that a winery has
been in existence for a long time were
in a VA's and older ABA so we're
thinking about we're thinking about that
establishing a reputation in New ABA
versus an old ABA but so what is sort of
interesting is that a VA longevity is
pretty flat but slightly increasing and
firm firm longevity is actually it's not
consistent it's not different from zero
but it's slightly negative and so so
we're thinking about that so why is that
because we would expect it to be
positive and the thing is that a lot of
the all a lot of the old wineries in
California were established around
prohibition and they the older ones and
they had they actually have a bad
reputation to overcome so that was sort
of interested so think gallo you know
for example so jug wines and then I'll
they're trying to produce better wines
but I actually think that they have to
overcome you know the grand children the
grandchildren of gallo are actually
about my age and they're too they wanted
their want to be winemakers on their own
but
they have to overcome sort of this jug
wine past that they had so I think that
sort of sort of been interesting that's
how I was thinking about at least so at
all yes yes
yeah so I will it's it's based on a
moving average and i'll give you the
paper so i'm not going to go through
that it's not it's not an exactly
standard deviation but it's it's a
calculation that is a standard deviation
like variance over time Everage the
average yes yes yeah so we average
within of all the wines that are listed
in wine spectator so it's an average of
their of the ABA okay alright so so just
a bit of discussion on this we see that
the price premium migrates to become
more specific as you get to the higher
as you get to the higher more expensive
wines and so so we were thinking about
we're trying to explain this effect and
we're thinking that search cost is
increases increases as you as you learn
more about specific wines and so so as
if you were if you were just if you're
just buying a cheap wine you might not
it is not worth your your time to search
to know about all the cheap wines to do
all that research but as you as you are
making a bigger investment say 100 or
you know eighty to a hundred dollars on
an expensive bottle of wine you're going
to research you are going to research
and want to make sure that that the cut
that you're not wrong so as the cost of
being wrong increases you increase your
search time that you put into that so
that's our that's our idea about about
why why it migrates yes
very natural so it goes haha given
dinner plans yes look at that over time
you look amazing huge increase in the
number 0 in bronze yeah okay so we only
well we're only looking at nineteen
ninety one to two thousand so we're
looking at the decade and there are just
a lot of lower-cost wines and then there
are fewer wines as you get more
expensive you know and so there there
are just a lot of wines and if you
research to everyone you it would be
costly and so instead of instead of
trying to find out about each about each
brand you might just you might just use
the collective reputation or say I think
I'll buy one from Napa you know that
that's in this price range and and do
that instead of instead of researching
each each brand of wine but i think i
think it is something that i'd like to
look at more into you know that how help
people about search cost and quality and
across across price segments because i
think there's there's something there
that could be interesting okay so then
so then lastly i wanted to also talk
about spatial relationships and so
that's sort of related to this idea and
this is what i worked on this with this
is still a working paper with men my
student and yang and then although i use
GIS in my dissertation i feel like i'm a
little rusty with all the GIS stuff so
we added Mike Brady who's my colleague
at russian state and he's a gif expert
so to make sure everything is up to date
in terms of the GIS so there have been
findings that rating spores and prices
are relate our spatial related why okay
it could be it could be collective
reputation that we've been talking about
it could be
a tasting effect or word of mouth so
here's here's a map of the tri-cities in
Washington and it's a wine map so you
can see that that people could people go
on people go on tasting trips and they
might go for example up into an area
where they can they can taste it eight
different eight different wineries and
so and so if you're located to a really
nice winery more people will go people
will talk about it so there might so
that they might be spatially related
because of that and then finally there
might be production in knowledge
externality so the that terroir for
example that that you might have there
might be better growing conditions and
soil conditions and drainage for the for
the production and there could also be
knowledge externalities so in the I know
in the Napa Valley they used to meet and
and just discuss how to make better wine
in there in their Valley so the growers
used to me and it I could say to I'm not
talking about the cost like that there
can be cost benefits to being located
close to each other also okay so
research questions again again you guys
are probably getting tired of the
Western wives but we're looking at
California and Washington wines and
we're interested in the spatial
interactions among among liners that are
in close proximity to each other and so
we want to we want to try to figure out
what's the nature of the spatial
relationship and how can we best model
and estimate this in and what is the
value of being located next to high
reputation winery so does that affect
does that affect your reputation okay so
this is darnell is just the first study
to consider the spatial effects at the
winery level a lot of studies had dummy
variables for four regions but no one
has actually used GIS data at the winery
level and so this adds to the hedonic
literature in wine by including these
spatial interactions and our results do
suggest that there that there exists
externalities and spillover effects in
the wine industry so that they are
spatially related and we might help a
potential wine investor in their in
their decision selecting a winery
location so we use we use GIS data
geographical information
systems we have so my my student
actually found the location of all the
red wines that are listed that of
wineries that produce wood red wine are
listed in wine spectator and here we
have and the Washington one didn't
actually show up but we have this is
coded by score but we have California
wines and then I have that I have the
Napa Valley sonoma napa sort of taken
out here but we have we can what we get
the we have a GIS program and we can we
get the exact latitude and longitude
evolved although wineries in these
states and we threw out wineries that we
didn't have in it that we couldn't get
an address war and so we have we have 79
wineries in Washington State and 876
wineries for California that that that
we could get an address for and that are
that are listed & Wine Spectator during
the years that we have that we have data
fork okay so similar similarly for each
winery our observations include prize
severities or talked about this rating
score we have cases of production year
of aging in region and the continuous
variables in this in this study are
averaged across varieties and vintage
for each wiry so each winery just has 11
squared it's an average ok because it's
otherwise you don't want a winery to be
its own neighbor you know okay so this
is hard to see actually it looks better
on my screen so but these are
descriptive statistics for the non
binary variables for California and
Washington and you can see that that
California does a lot better than
Washington and so here we have we have a
price on the s4 or so the the median
price is 20
of these is $23 and for California to a
little bit higher 2558 but you can see
it starts it starts diverging on the
higher end so the 75th percentile for
for watching states almost thirty
dollars 2975 and for California it's 38
so California is a lot higher and I
didn't have a maximum for each so the
maximum for I listened in Washington's
almost 60 it's two over twelve hundred
dollars for for California so I think
actually Washington has higher wines now
but but back then higher price minds now
but back then it was the highest one
with sixty dollars okay so so we have we
have scorer number of cases age and then
we use macro regions of production not
the ABA is just macro region so in Napa
a variant uncle California Sonoma south
coast carneros Sierra Foothills
Mendocino from California and then we
use for macro regions for Washington
Columbia Valley Napa Valley Walla Walla
and puget sound okay
uh because of actually because of
observations you know because we didn't
since we average everything we don't
have that many observations you know to
have to have all those abs okay so
there's sort of two approaches to
spatial modeling when is a spatial leg
model and when is a spatial error model
and so we decided to use the spatial leg
model and rather than that in the
spatial error model so the error model
says that they're the court that the
relationship the spatial relationship is
in the error term were saying that it's
in that in the main part so it's not in
the error term okay and so so now we had
to now we have to figure out we have to
figure out functional form I won't talk
too much about this but we want to so
what we're doing is we have a we have a
spatial light parameter that's this row
here then we have we have price and and
we can we we need to figure out what the
best spatial relating relationship is so
this is a vector of prices it has that
it has the other prices too so it's a so
what sort of weight we want to have
there and then we have the other
variables in error term and so I think I
let me see I have this in the next slide
so what we decided you could we could
have this as we could have something
like a we could have a distance formula
so we could base it on how far the
neighbors are or we but what we decided
to do we thought that that that would be
distance would not work as well but we
might still explore that but what we
decided to do is have the criterion of
the k-nearest neighbors so that the some
level some number of nearest neighbors
affects your price and we would
determine that empirically okay and then
and then we also we also did a I'll talk
about that a little bit more on another
side but we also did a box Cox
transformation to get the best
functional form between between in the
hedonic price relationship and
interestingly there differ
and across California and Washington so
in watching States just a semi-log
silagra price is the best fit with with
the functional form and for California's
to the negative it's a negative exponent
to the negative point 25 is the best fit
for California and so because of this in
interpreting the marginal effects that
you'll have opposite signs okay I'll
talk about that a little bit more both
then so what we estimate is this
transform price times the spatial
grading relationship and then the
variables we include our score cases age
and then regions okay so we we explore
the spatial relationship a little bit
and we find we use the global brands I
statistic and we find that both a price
and score for both states are positively
related to each other ok so there's
positive clustering at the global level
price clustering is stronger than score
clustering which is find that's
interesting that that there is some sort
of perception or economic effect that
that this measure of quality is less
correlated than price we estimated so
when we first did this we estimated your
as I said we're used nearest neighbors
for our spatial wait and when we first
did I said let's let's try 125 and see
and see where we get a maximum because I
always think you know there'll be you
know it won't be that many neighbors
that will affect your price and so for
Washington State we got the we got the
best value at it we use the ASC
statistic to choose it but for for
watching state we based on the ast to
see statistics the three nearest
neighbors best where was give us the
best fit but then for for California we
had the best fit at five okay so that
makes me worry because that's on the
boundary so I said just keep going you
know and tell it and tell you you know I
tell you can until you go and so so my
pork my poor PhD student I had her
estimate out till 65
and and she found that the best for
California was 35 so but what's sort of
so I mean maybe this is saying to to do
more to do more work but also what is
sort of interesting so I thought that
there the number of wineries in
California is about 11 times Washington
so I just said let's see what percentage
that is of the wires and so
interestingly it's four percent of
Washington and it's four percent for
California so probably I probably do
need to do some more work on this but I
thought that was interesting that okay
at least that's consistent so so we
estimated so we asked to I'll show you
the results with just the k-nearest
neighbors and the in the and then and
then without any spatial spatial term
but the statistics from we did well
likelihood ratio and lagrange multiplier
tests i'll confirm that the the
parameter describing so the role
parameter describing the spatial
correlation is statistically different
from zero and has a positive sign and so
so neighbors neighbors do have a
significantly positive effect on on own
price and so definitely adds value good
neighbors do have value and that's not
surprising on the on the price side so
here's and i suppress the i suppress the
macro regions here's our results for for
california and washington so so
california's raised to that negative
exponent so the marginal effects to
expect the positive sign except for
except for the role because the prices
are transformed on both sides so
so pretty actually pretty consistent
that we have this point three three
parameter very significant for both and
we get we get we get greater explanatory
value it's a better model when we
consider the spatial sort of interesting
to think about that that the the spatial
part then makes the other makes the
other parameters and we have all the
expected signs that we get another
parameters it makes them it makes them
it diminishes their effect for for all
for all the other parameters so just
some interesting just exploring how how
neighbors might affect might affect
wines so the conclusion the conclusion
from from this is that that reputations
we find that reputations are attached to
states regions and project names there
is an incentive to free ride on the
region reputation but it can be offset
some degree by incentives to improve
your own firm or brand reputation
reputations can have different effects
on price quantile and we have the search
classic explanation that we might want
to explore some more the spatial the
spatial estimations provide some
additional evidence that high performing
wineries have significant and positive
effects on on wineries prices for both
for both states wineries but this I have
to warn you know we always wanted to
make our work relevant you know to to
wine producers I have to warn that this
doesn't necessarily meaning that
choosing a location next to a high
reputation winery will generate the
maximum profit because this is only
focusing on the market side not on the
cost so it could be it could be
that's already capitalized in to land
prices okay for one thing you know so
and then another thing we could also
even think about this in a dynamic sense
that that over over time you might get
the you know the the gentleman the
gentleman vineyard owner who doesn't
really know anything about wine but has
a lot of money who's just trying it out
and you could see you could see fall
falling quality over time so then I want
to talk a little bit just about future
research so first of all I did I did
have a reviewer on that so the first
paper the first paper in the the model
just the model papers its forthcoming
now but I had a in the journal bag econ
the british journal but i had some i did
have a reviewer say well this is really
just a credence good you know and i we
need to you need to address that you
need to model that secretes good and so
I was thinking well that's another paper
you know that's that's not something I
can just do you know but but it's sort
of it is an interesting issue that if if
if consumers can't really judge quality
then wine might be a combination of and
experience give no credence good based
on marketing and it Creedence good based
on marketing and related to perceived
quality and reputation and so so I could
explore that I've thought about this a
little bit I have a head of a
theoretical paper on this and I and I
also look at credence goods in terms of
in a game theory model for organic foods
so it would be I think it would be an
interesting thing to think about I just
looked at credence goods for a single
firm but it would be interesting to
think about in in a in a collective or a
dual reputation and then another thing
that is interesting that is how do new
reputations form and so this is what I'm
working on with Brad so to give a plug
for our research where we're we're doing
a experiment starting tomorrow brad has
an SAR a product project on on new wine
regions and so you guys have probably
all heard either we or Brad talked about
it but we have we're using auctions from
California Oregon and Virginia with
different
information treatments no information
information about the regions and then
tying the region to the unassociated
region region in France and we're
thinking like reputation spillover so if
it if it's similar to France how will
that affect how will that affect the
evaluation for the new wine uh then
another thing that I'm sort of
interested in is thinking about networks
and reputation so I think network
economics is really interesting so and
you could you could have applications it
could be interesting to think about
University University faculty and
doctoral programs so so you know there's
we keep all sorts of data on ourselves
you know so when that be interesting to
to go more into that I also so going
from university faculty cattle auctions
I I was just talking to um I'm
forgetting her name at the moment but at
a recent conference a woman from Texas
A&M and she was talking about that that
the large operators would receive a
higher price in the kabosh holes than
the small than the small cooperatives
and then so those small cooperatives
formed together and certified their
their cattle and then they got prices
that were indistinguishable from large
operators so I said let's team up so I
like your data so so that's what might
be something that I I'm working on in
the future so with that I finished I was
actually worried about that I wouldn't
be able to squeeze it all inside maybe I
rest a little bit too much but I so I
thought this was funny this is a picture
I gave but I give it a different talk
online at UC Davis a few years ago and
Julian Austin brought wine for everyone
and got the permit I guess so I had I
had thought about bringing wine today
and some very wise gentleman from the
from coffee said someone said ask for
forgiveness instead of permission but
but I guess I looked out in the night is
that we just have cookies so any without
any questions
yeah i think if anyone has any questions
for Jill here or they turn your mic on
or off they ask questions looks like
someone's standing up okay I can
we want this off so yes a question from
Geneva for variation on your way to
wineries which have one business address
which could be a Modesto but are making
bridal wine or 88 liddie eight wines
from multiple areas how did that equals
you're okay that that is that that is a
concern I need to there is there is
there are regulations about the
percentage of wine that is that is from
a region to be labeled as that region I
think it's something like eighty percent
but but that said it is not necessarily
tied to the actual address so that that
is a bed as a concern I so I only I only
have the I do have a variable for estate
wines but there which means that it's
grown right on the it's grown at the at
the winery but the data is limited on
that so I get that is that is a drawback
of my of my work so I've thought about
that I've thought about that it could be
maybe it shows the marketing effective
and more that maybe that terroir doesn't
matter as much as as the marketing the
marketing effective of that location
that if you're in this great location
next to high-profile wineries it is
positive I don't know if that satisfied
you but that's it is it is a it is a
drawback and I probably should have
discussed that actually that that we can
we can have wines that are from
different locations that are that are
sold by salt into different address they
source their grapes month from other
wineries or other vineyards
yes
quality parameters score pressures of
those other
scores and then
nearby was was there their reputation
based on school
high-profile winery with new properties
that are high scoring lines versus the
properties that are
so we didn't in this in this well
initially we did we just explored the
spatial relationships for both for both
score and price and found the higher the
higher relationship or the higher
correlation with price and then and then
we just looked at spatially with price
we did not consider other scores we have
the score of the own winery but not the
scores of the other wine but that that
could be done that's interesting I I
didn't really think about combining the
spatial both spatial aspects in the same
yeah I'm trying to think of how to do
that actually Jerry
california in the situation of New York
State how can I ask you a question first
drop this down
when I going to have the north side very
well-stocked move through this fool's
journey I've been there a few times
second I have numerous selections of
wines from California there is one shell
for northwestern United States there are
a few wineries or Washington and Oregon
if you go to a well-stocked wine store
where you live in Washington how many
New York points can you select and take
a few rough figures when we do studies
of in New York we find out that way over
half the percentage of sales of their
wineries come from the tasting room and
wondering how this inputs is your model
well I think it fits the spatial model
very well you know because that if your
if your closest neighbors are are good i
think that you'll you'll visit you'll
visit those miners more and you'll buy
more right so so is aba the right thing
look at maybe minefields yeah well so in
this one in this spatial model it's
based on nearest neighbors so I think I
think a VA still does matter still does
have a positive effect but maybe the
neighbors are more important in for New
York yes of the spatial so it'd be
interesting to get in New York date and
see and see if it's different because it
probably is and we probably have a
different we probably have a different
weighting matrix to so that'd be fun
it'd be fun to look at and see in
compare so but we'd want to have like so
have you know white wines also these are
Reds you know so it's come down to your
consumers
maybe somebody else
I library but
that's yeah that's interesting
any questions
I just had a comment and a question and
I notice that you and me and everyone
who doesn't scrubs use the wine
spectator scores and how I've never seen
anybody use
just think about that
how much our results image on these
particular set of scores we always use
that's just common and then my question
was about these a bas when we use these
time series the whole notion of a BAS is
actually quite
hey was 30 years
there's one
in the course of some of your data sets
you know 180 a game
or the blonde or APA's control that are
people that when they're looking at this
question of a bas over time series as a
v8's change or you just stick with
whatever you had to start all of that in
our in our data we have observations for
hav a that we use for each for each year
so we have we have ten years so I wonder
what the what the growth in a BAS was in
California Washington for the from 91 to
2000 so it might be before the huge
upswing so yeah yes yes yeah
91
so we're trying for consistency I'm
trying to think of we we probably don't
have all the sub abs in there now so
yeah so we have Napa for example as an
ABA and we might not have all the sub
APA's you know it needs us so so we're
using more of the bigger a VA's and
that's probably better for our analysis
like this yeah yes and why inspector so
we do sort of lean on wine spectator and
it's just it's a nice data source you
know so it's the so as economist it's
always good to have data and we they
they offer they have electronic versions
of the magazine and they have all the
data that you can ready to analyze you
know so we have the price we have the
cases produced there's all sorts of data
that you can use and do a lot less so
there so with that there's been a lot of
work on line economics and hence a
journal of wine economics you know and
so it's it's easy to easy to obtain data
and you can try out new things but but
it also it might not be the best but you
have to choose one right you know so I
don't know if wine spectator's any
better than wine enthusiast or wine
advocate but you have to choose one and
this one is all already electronically
available
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu